and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 172 today
we're gonna talk about your money
problem any problems yeah Ryan are you
saying I shouldn't invested in all that
Bitcoin actually right invested in white
coin we because we're talking about
money problems as you know we don't do
interviews here on the minimalist
podcast but occasionally we invite our
friends onto the show to help us answer
your questions and today we're here with
Rachel cruse you've actually heard her
on our show before what do you what are
you doing in town you're you're just
doing the circuit talking about money
all the above here for the back on I
love you guys I quote you guys like well
all the time seriously but yeah here in
LA
just doing some media a couple shows and
got to hang out with you guys
great we did your YouTube show last
summer and we'll put a link to that in
the show notes the Rachel Cruz show and
now the Rachel Cruz show is also a
podcast well and you guys were on the
podcast audio from the show and put it
on the podcast yes yes indeed and we're
going to do a conversation with you for
the podcast as well so you all can check
that out wherever you listen to your
podcast I say we go ahead and dive into
these questions about money problems
yeah alright our first question today is
from Lauren in Wichita I am paying off
my student loans in a vehicle loan I'm
having trouble inspiring my boyfriend to
be on the same page for budgeting we
lived together while having separate
bank accounts but since he has no loans
just a house payment he says he does not
need a budget when shared expenses that
creates an issue for me as groceries
since I do most of the meal planning I
end up paying more out of my own food
budget each month on what I think should
be a 50/50 budget Josh and Ryan how do
you approach this with your partners and
Rachel what advice do you have for me to
navigate living like no one else when
right now that includes my partner
alright so I think it's pretty clear
Rachel you do they need a budget
yes I second that and I always take a
little bit of a different approach when
it comes to relationships and money
because I I do believe that once you're
married is when you combine the finances
it's kind of my stance and so for you
guys living together I would still
recommend separate budgets at this point
and to figure out okay so what what is
it who who is responsible for who and is
it fair for it to be 50/50 yeah probably
so if X amounts going out for food then
what's he gonna be paying and so looking
at that and saying how we're gonna be
able to live like this you know and
still be intentional because that's the
key overall you want to create these
good money habits no matter who you are
in life and one of those is being
intentional with your money it's really
hard to win financially when you're not
in control and your money is controlling
you so Lauren here is living with her
boyfriend and right now it sounds to me
like what you're saying is the budget
needs to be treated it's sort of like a
roommate situation if you were living
with one of your girlfriends and you
just happen to be living together you
would share the expenses accordingly
right exactly and it looks to me like
right now what they need to do is is
they still have to budget even if he
doesn't want to sit down and do his own
individual budget he's still responsible
for his portion just like your roommate
would be responsible yeah exactly that's
that's what I was gonna suggest is if
she can go to her partner and say hey I
know that you don't want to do a budget
it is kind of a pain in the butt to do a
budget but I will help you with her I
will do that budget for you I mean I'm
sure that he loves her very much and
that he wants to make her happy and if
that's the case I'm sure that he will
support her if she really explains to
them how this is important to her but
I'll tell you what if what a couples
argue about the most Josh sex and money
sex and money absolutely so if you are
on or if you are not on the same page
with money in your relationship I mean
that is a perfect recipe for discontent
so maybe maybe he doesn't want the
budget maybe that's you know too much
trouble for him but sometimes in
relationships we gotta give we got to
take we got a we got to treat that sbox
equally Josh and I we talk a lot about
how in every relationship there is an Us
box and we have to put in the us box and
then sometimes we take from the us box
but if one of the partners are is just
taking and the other one is giving
again like that is going to be a perfect
recipe for discontent it's it becomes a
parasitic relationship you don't even
realize it that that happened to me I
wrote about it in our book everything
that remains I had a relationship that
was going really really well and then
over time what happened was it started
not going as well and I didn't
understand why at the time and I think
right now this is where Lauren is she's
starting to experience those pangs of
discontent and what I realized is that
us box I was taking and taking a little
bit more and I stopped giving as much as
I was giving now sometimes you're in a
season of your life where you can give
more I'm not just talking about money
but sometimes it's a tension it's time
it's other resources that you have your
energy your talent your skill set there
are different resources that you can
give however if you stop giving what
you're able to give and you just keep
taking and taking you don't realize that
you're becoming a parasite this is what
parasites do and I think what Lauren is
realizing right now is like oh no this
is an uneven relationship I'm hopeful
though I think maybe your boyfriend
right now just doesn't realize that it's
uneven it's very normal relationships
like very very common that opposites are
going to attract and so when it comes to
the money portion one of you is going to
love the idea of a budget which is
Lauren right like she feels in control
she knows what's going on she's probably
the person that's ten minutes early to
every appointment like you don't mean
it's just those people function like
that and then you're gonna have more of
the free spirits which is probably her
boyfriend where it's like ah not so much
you know like and it's not in his
gifting and what's funny is I'm actually
more of the free spirit and my
relationship with my husband he's more
of like the nerd and like loves to do it
and I'm more than free spent like
everything's gonna work out it's fine
don't worry and so I've had to learn to
be like you know what in order to win in
order to kind of have some maturity and
grow up a little bit right like I have
to be in tension with my money and do
the budget so there is this
give-and-take Lauren I would say I don't
think that you're at this case but I do
meet some nerds and they're so dang
legalistic it's like if not everything's
by the book and it's like oh my gosh
they drive me crazy I'm like have a
little grace have a little grace but
also if you are the free spirit out
there like you have to learn to delay
pleasure and make a plan and there's a
part of that that's growing up that you
have to be purposeful and so there's
kind of a game
and take as well and but there but it's
very normal very common Lauren that you
guys are opposites on this so maybe he
has something to do with the language
right maybe he's just afraid sometimes
we're afraid of confronting our own
problems and so that word budget is
terrifying for him maybe in order to get
him closer to a budget we just start
talking about well what's our plan for
our finances right in adjusting the
language a little bit so that it doesn't
freak him out it eases him into at least
starting to think about money and your
life together as your lives continue to
converge you know you you have to have a
plan you have to have shared values you
have to have similar beliefs if you want
to be able to continue to to move down
the same path together because otherwise
you're gonna be going down two different
paths you're going down two different
paths
possibly two different destinations
otherwise yeah I think too I know when
Mariah and I when we first did our
budget mariah put together this like
nice spreadsheet that I mean it was very
very organized very very good but I
wouldn't even touch yeah exactly I would
I would just you know bait I basically
you know gave her all my account
information and I'm like you please like
track all of this spending
I don't wanna that's a beautiful
spreadsheet but I just don't want to
touch that spreadsheet but then I
finally downloaded the every dollar app
and like that actually makes it um I
don't want to say fun but there is
something gratification like when I'm
going through my expenses and entering
these line items and just keeping track
of it it's like this um I don't know it
just it makes it again I don't want to
say more fun it makes it more tolerable
and maybe that's where Lauren's partner
is that he's can't even tolerate it
right now but yes using different
language using a tool that makes it a
little bit easier to keep track of the
budget like this is what is going to
help him tolerate it a little bit more
ultimately we talk about removing some
of the friction and right now there's
too much friction I think some friction
is good it creates traction to get you
where you're going but right now there's
a little bit too much and using an app
that makes it a bit easier than just
writing things down on a spreadsheet
making it less intimidating for him is
really the direction that you want to go
in develop a plan together so that you
can move forward all right before we
move on to our little
around this week we have five more
voicemail questions we're gonna answer
on our maximal episode on patreon in the
meantime we'd love to hear what you have
to say so if you have a comment or a tip
about money problems tell us about your
money problems leave us a voicemail for
0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 or email a voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists comm or
air our favorite comments & tips on a
future episode and stay tuned to the end
of this episode for this week's listener
comments and tips and here is a pro tip
for you write down your question before
calling Ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media indeed we do
so Rachel we're on Twitter and Facebook
and Instagram at the minimalists and you
are at Rachel Cruz I think on all of the
above that's right alright so you can
follow Rachel over there during the
lightning round this is where Ryan and I
each do our best to answer every
question was just a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal Maxim's in our
show notes or at least podcast Sean does
so you can copy and share our pith the
answers on social media if you'd like
now don't worry Rachel what we really do
is we monitor on a bit and we just
ramble and what happens is we just talk
a lot and then we come up with something
pithy and Shawn puts it in the show
notes so our first question is from
Jeremy you want to read that one Ryan
yeah Jeremy he asked us should a
divorced dad save for all their child's
college or only half even though the ex
wife isn't financially savvy hmm so so
hey this makes me think Rachel about
like do you want to send your kid to
half a college the first two years like
yeah because I did that I don't have a
college degree personally but I ended up
with college debt which is like through
the worst scenario right so what what
kind of advice would you give to Jeremy
here and he's a dad they're they're
divorced should he just save for half
what do you what do you tend the
restaurant el Jeremy first and foremost
he has to take care of his future so we
always recommend getting out of debt
getting an emergency fund and funding
retirement first because those things
are going to set you up well
child may or may not go to college you
don't know but retirement is going to
happen so focusing on those steps first
and then when you get to the point that
you have some money left over and you're
like okay I can start investing so yeah
I would say open up a 529 and ESA start
putting some money in it if there's not
enough money there when little junior a
little Johnny goes off to college then
little Johnny's got to get to work he's
got to apply for scholarships and grants
you know it's gonna be part of his
responsibility as well but if you're
able to do the sooner you know when the
child is younger then those funds will
grow mathematically speaking and
hopefully there'll be some money in
there for college but I would say don't
break your back I think a lot of parents
put this weight on themselves to pay for
their kids college well if they can it's
a huge blessing I mean what a gift like
that's amazing but you are not a bad
parent
if you don't right yeah I totally agree
I love that advice of you know putting
your financial security first and it's
not like you're being stingy with your
money but it's about planning ahead and
making sure that you do have the
expenses you know are going to happen
that you have those covered I mean I
don't know about you man but if I had
kids with a partner who I wasn't married
to and if I say for half of the college
like I would be I you know I just
wouldn't take that risk because when the
kids turn 18 it's like it whether it
doesn't sound like you know she's gonna
make the best decision so whether you've
got half a college fund or not if the
other person doesn't do their part then
it's going to be a disaster
well I don't know I I don't know that I
agree with that I think that having half
the money is better than having none of
the money right and and so I think what
Rachel said is basically take care of
yourself first you know secure your own
oxygen mask before helping others
because otherwise like if you're broke
but you're still trying to put some
money into a college fund for your kid
that isn't going to be helpful but if
you're taking care of you're out of debt
you're saving for retirement you've paid
off your house or you're working toward
paying off your house then yet yes you
want to if you want to put some money
aside for your kid great if it's not
enough to fund their full college
experience that's great my pithy answer
to this is don't pursue the goal pursue
the why behind the goal because why
you said why are you saving this money
woods because you hope your kid has a
better future you don't care about the
piece of paper it says look I graduated
from Miami University or whatever it
what what you're what you're excited
about what you're looking forward to is
I want the most opportunities for my
child
and maybe they aren't going to go to
college at all or if they do then maybe
they're gonna have to pay for some of it
and you can help out a little bit with
that you know what man that's a good
perspective because you're right like if
he does save half of it and let's say
they get to a point where both of them
do you want to go to college yeah it's
it's much better to be in half as much
debt then the full ride for sure I mean
here's my pithy answer more money
planning less money problems that's
really that's that's really what it
comes down to I mean we all we all you
know we all have some kind of money
problems - to an extent the more we plan
the more we take care of ourselves and
the more that we we stick to that plan I
mean that's kind of the key part of it -
right yes the less the less problems
we're gonna have when it comes to money
as we get older yes indeed all right the
next question is from Shai how do you
stay motivated
what paying off debt so so Rachel I mean
that's often a thing people hit these
they get really excited in the moment
right yeah they go to one of your Smart
Money events or they read your book you
you have a great book with respect to
kids there's smart money smart kids and
they get really excited they want to
take a million bits of action this day
or this week or even this month but then
of course excitement only lasts so long
when you hit that first roadblock you
hit the drudgery you you get your next
paycheck in your life but I want to I'm
gonna splurge a little bit how do i how
do i stay motivated what would you tell
shy that she's trying to pay off debt
how does she stay motivated yeah I would
say a couple of things you have to
realize that your money journey
especially getting out of debt it's a
marathon it's not a sprint and so it is
going to take time and in our world
today and you guys know this but it's
like we want things immediately like
instant gratification is just ramp it
like we can have anything we want right
when we want it thanks to credit cards
or even information on our iPhone like
so we're not used to functioning with
this long-term game plan and so there's
going to be patience and it's
to be a character quality and a
character building moment for you to
realize that I have to stay diligent I
have to continue down the path because
what what is what have I gotten so far
right so like if you're halfway through
getting out of debt you can look back
and say this is what I've done and yes I
still have half half more to go but it's
in the grand scheme of things though
it's set short-term sacrifice for
long-term game it takes on people on our
plan an average of 18 to 24 months get
completely debt-free but their house and
so two years and a life is like that
right I mean like and so and it's not
that you can't have all these fun things
later because that's fine but like right
now this is what you're sticking to and
also know you're why why are you
choosing to go down this journey why did
you start it was it because you were
stressed out and you're freaked out you
were losing sleep at night you had no
security you want your kids to have a
better life than you did you want to get
to retirement and actually be able to
retire like like what was your why and
focusing on that because it's that
bigger picture that's important yeah it
sounds to be like what you're saying is
you have to pan out from the immediate
problem in order to see the solution
what you're saying yeah in the moment
you really want to like spend this money
or you don't feel motivated so you're
gonna waste your money or whatever if
you pan out just a little bit you
realize like oh this isn't nearly as big
of a problem as I thought and I know I
can tackle it and I'd say have these
moments of okay once we've paid off you
know an X amount of debt maybe you do go
out to a nice dinner right like have
these checkmarks don't let that be a
part of your whole you know your entire
lifestyle cuz obviously it'll be hard to
get out of debt if you haven't
sacrificed your lifestyle but maybe you
do have these pinpoints throughout the
way of like okay once we hit this we
will go celebrate a little bit right so
like so you can kind of plan it out as
well yeah I was I was gonna say and this
isn't only part of my pithy answer but I
was gonna say that you do have the
opportunity to still budget for these
these non-essential things that you want
to have in your life I mean yes you
might not be able to go out to eat every
single week maybe not even every single
month but yeah setting those benchmarks
kind of rewarding rewarding yourself you
know to a certain extent not not over
rewarding yourself like I'm not
encouraging people to go and get a
credit card to to reward themselves that
way but but you know deprivation
especially when it comes to paying off
finances or when it
to minimalism I mean debit deprivation
it is something I think that you might
have to go through temporarily but it
definitely is not going to be a
long-term thing it's not going to it's
not sustainable long term so yes
throwing in those little benchmarks I
think are super super important
my pet the answer is debt free is the
new American Dream and like to me like
knowing that I don't have any debt like
right now I could you know Josh Josh
could fire me he could leave me and
there could be no more minimalist and we
take all of our books you know off the
internet or whatever I mean let's say
something like crazy like that happen
right I could turn my life around on a
dime because I don't have any debt and
that feeling is it's it's just an
incredibly freeing feeling so you talk
about the American Dream you talk about
freedom right absolutely and if you want
freedom part of that freedom not all of
it but part of this financial freedom
gives you the ability to move to make
changes to pivot in your life to prepare
for emergencies these are all things
that are really important my pithy
answer is knowing what lies beyond the
landscape propels us toward the horizon
it's the why that you're talking about
right now when you don't feel motivated
it's because you can't see past the
horizon but if you know what is past
there you're gonna keep traveling in
that direction I've got one little tip
for the why when I was starting to get
into a workout routine I did a really
good job of you know getting up at 7:00
when that alarm clock went off and then
I hit snooze and then it'd be 7:30 and
then I hit snooze again and then it's 8
o'clock and then you know by the time
that you know 8:30 9:00 o'clock rolled
around I'm just getting my first cup of
coffee and oh I've got work to do so now
I can't go work out I was really good at
putting it off but one thing that I did
do that helped me is I wrote down on my
notepad in my iPhone just all of these
reasons why I wanted to work out so
what's up you know I want to be
healthier I want to live a long life I
want to be able you know to date more I
want to go on more dates and date more
girls I mean whatever those reasons are
I would before I hit the snooze button
the first time I would get my iPhone out
and I would pull up that that notes and
I would read the reasons why and now
this isn't a magic bullet answer it's
not going to lay
you know propel you into you know making
your all of your goals come to fruition
100% but it is little things like that
that can kind of give you the leverage
you need to take the action yes indeed
okay now it's time for our added value
portion of the show this is where we
talk about something has added value to
our lives
recently Ryan what's adding value to
your life man we we just recently did
that patreon podcast that that special
podcast about gentrification what was
the name of that the life tidying magic
of gentrification and through my
research and looking up things with
gentrification I came across this
podcast called science versus and
specifically the podcast the science
versus gentrification is what we kind of
discussed on that episode but man that
entire podcast is awesome because it
kind of it takes these very I guess
sometimes can be partisan topics right
like gentrification or like gender or
just just these topics that we kind of
argue about but it takes a scientific
approach with it
and it really does do the research it's
very its diverse it's not like it's just
you know people giving their opinions
it's research and I would just recommend
anyone who likes to kind of dive into
stuff analytically check out science
versus it's great let's put a link to
that in the show notes for me there is a
new album from a band or really a
collaboration called better oblivion
community center have you heard of this
so you know my favorite album from last
year was Phoebe Bridgers okay she and
Conor Oberst the lead singer of bright
eyes they formed this band or
collaboration together called better
oblivion Community Center and the title
of the album is the same name better
oblivion Community Center I think at the
end of this episode we'll play you out
with the lead song on there it's called
didn't know what I was in for and so
you'll be able to check that out you can
listen to the album as well wherever you
get music these days alright let's move
on to right here right now so we talked
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalist before we do that I want
to say thank you to Rachael Cruz check
out her new podcast it's called the
Rachael Cruz show we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well let's
talk about three things that are going
on in our life
recently we put up a video for screen
with Saturday's Ryan dude Jordan great
work man we all went out uh it was
podcast Sean
he had this audio recorder that looked
like my grandmother owned it was like a
tape it was a cassette tape right yeah
yes it was a cassette tape so we went
out on a Saturday using only analog
equipment it was crazy
Jordan had actual film I think it was
like nine minutes of film if you shot at
18 frames per second and so we shot this
thing at 18 frames per second we went to
this park outdoors and we're like
skipping rocks and like jumping around
together and the Palin around on a
Saturday it happens to be the same Park
that they film the intro to The Andy
Griffith Show yes yeah so it's yeah it's
woodsy it has a very like Nate feel of
nature going on plus we were flannel so
that equals nature right exactly animal
equality
so you can check that out on YouTube
it's just called screen 'less Saturdays
it was a it was a fun little experiment
we we in that video we talked about the
three different ways that you can
experience green lasat er day because
it's not a draconian set of rules there
are three different ways that you can
you can do screen 'less saturdays if you
want to participate also I'm teaching a
writing class it's called how to write
better if you want to learn how to
improve your writing whether you're
thinking about writing your first book
you want to write some blog post or you
just want to improve your emails I've
had literally medical doctors take this
class and high school students take this
class I've had foreign language students
take the class and I believe the rising
tide lifts all boats if you want to
learn how to write better it's a four
week course over at how to write better
dot-org you can sign up over there and
then have you checked out our side
project it's called minimalism life and
you can find it at minimalism dot life
you can also follow it on social media I
think the best place to fall minimalism
life on social media is either Twitter
which is just at minimalism or at
minimalism life on Instagram if you want
to beautifully curated Instagram feed
minimalism life is the place to go but
check out the website we have a bunch of
different contributors people writing
about minimalism if you want to write as
well there's a place to submit potential
writings for the future you can check
that out minimalism
life alright y'all you can comment on
this episode over at youtube.com slash
the minimalists and if you want our show
notes in your inbox you can sign up for
our email list over at the minimalists
comm you just go to the website and
there's a little box up there you enter
your email address
you also receive our simple Sundays
emails each week but you'll never
receive any spam no we would never do
that to you alright one more thing this
week we have five more voicemail
questions about being responsible with
money teaching children how to budget
about staying with a job you hate so you
can pay off your debt about how to save
for emergencies and about paying for
health care coverage if you want to hear
our answers to these questions you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different long-form
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about our
flawed habits our family lives our
struggles our personal relationships our
emotions and our insecurities Plus
patreon is the best way for us to fund
this podcast and keep it a hundred
percent advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also get access to our entire
back catalogue of more than a hundred
private podcast episodes find all the
details and all the good stuff including
an additional podcast episode every week
over at the minimalists com slash
support Ryan what else as always I just
want to encourage people to read more
and get informed and now here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hi I have two tips so on a
patreon podcast Ryan mentioned that he
wasn't even aware of how many
advertisements he was seeing on a
certain service and I live in New York
so there are advertisements everywhere
on the subway at the bus stop and so I
just started saying to myself in my head
advertisement every
time that I see an advertisement that
way I'm a little bit more aware of what
I'm seeing my other tip is I would
highly recommend the book the power of
habit
it is fascinating for many reasons one
of those is related to advertisements
they talk about specific companies and
the kind of mental manipulations and
data that they study to try to get us to
buy things that we do not need and for
me just kind of knowing that when I
enter a store helps me reason through
maybe things that I have the urge to buy
that aren't on my list this is Rochelle
from Saginaw Michigan I just finished
the subtract episode and I have a
suggestion for Kelly and anyone who's
trying to listen more I have adapted to
practice of adjusting my posture when I
realized that I'm in a situation where I
need to listen for example if I'm seated
I stack my hands in my lap with my palms
up and this reminds myself that I am
here to receive what the other person
has to say I hope this tip helps Kelly
and anyone else trying to listen more
alright so that's it for now you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalists if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists comm
you'll also receive our simple Sundays
emails each week and if you leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listen y'all we'll see you next time and
minimus